Anyhow, so today I'm going to
try and wrap up a few loose ends.
So,
uh,
I'm going to try and talk about
the high watermark of finance,
which is basically cap
Bam and black shoals,
both of which we've almost talked about,
almost finished talking about.
And I'm going to talk in the
middle about social security,
which we never finished.
My social security plan is I hope to deal
with all three of these things today.
So just to wrap up the cap m,
the cap M had two main ideas.
The first idea was diversification.
And the second main idea,
as we said,
was the trade off between risk and return.
Okay.
Shakespeare had both of these ideas.
He understood that you're safer if he's
got each of your bolts on a different
ocean and he understood that if you want,
if you're going to take a a high risk,
you'd better get a high return.
Otherwise no one was willing to take it.
And so he made that very clear. In fact,
I think the whole point of
the play is about economics.
The merchant of Venice and he made
both of these principles very clear,
but he couldn't quantify them
and he couldn't mathematize them.
And the capital asset pricing
model gives a mathematical,
quantifiable form to both and up quite
shocking recommendation in both cases.
So just to draw those two pictures,
for those of you who didn't hear it last
night, if you do Tobin's famous picture,
this is the Markowitz Tobin
Markowitz Tobin capitol market line,
they called it,
you pour it and it's very important to
keep straight what's on the diagram.
There's the standard deviation
of any acid per dollar.
So here I'm writing the price,
so it's per dollar.
And here is the expectation
of the acid per dollar.
So Pi of why I'm calling that the
price. Okay, let's just per dollar,
and I'm not going to go
over what we derived before,
but we noticed that if you take in you,
if you took all the risky assets,
you know,
any risky assets going to have per dollar,
if it's priced some standard
deviation and some expectation,
you can write down all the risky assets
and you can combine them and you'll get
a possibility set that looks like this.
Okay?
So the diversification already shows up
in this picture because you don't have,
you combine this asset and this asset,
you're going to get possibilities
by putting half your money in each,
not on a straight line between them,
but on some curved line that's much
better because you're reducing your risk.
Okay? And so, uh, Tobin,
so mark what's already had that
curve and this picture in mind,
Tobin added the risk was acid,
which she put. And then he said,
well,
if there's a risk plus acid,
everybody's going to do the
same thing and they're going to,
everyone's going to choose the same point.
It's better for everybody.
So this is the optimal risky portfolio
and it has to be equal to the market.
Because if everybody's smart
enough to figure out what to do,
they're all going to do the same
thing and everyone's going to whatever
everybody holds. That's by
definition in the market. Okay?
So Toban show that everybody should
choose something on this capital market
line.
And so everybody should,
everybody should split as money
between the market and a risk.
We'll Sasson put your money in the bank.
We're only entire market.
That was his recommendation.
And that was the beginning of the
whole idea of index investing. Okay,
so that was the first idea.
First most important idea.
Now how could you investing,
how could you test this?
Well,
you could simply test every
fun in history and compare,
you know,
of x,
so called experts and see if those
guys could get you above this line.
So by the way,
the slope of the line,
one more thing is the
slope equal Sharpe ratio.
Okay? So everybody's trying to get
the highest sharp ratio they can.
And if you end up, you know, if you have
this portfolio, you've made a mistake,
you haven't held the optimal one,
then the slope of your performance
will be a lower Sharpe ratio than that.
You're the slope of this,
which is the sharp ratio of that point
is worse than the slope of that which is
the sharp ratio.
This point,
the Sharpe ratio will remember
is the expectation per dollar
minus what you can get in the riskless
asset per dollar divided by the standard
deviation of y per
dollar, let's say. Okay,
so that's the,
that's just the slope of this line.
So we can measure performance of a
portfolio manager by the sharp ratio.
Everyone should try and get
the highest sharp ratio.
The upshot of diversification is you
should buy a little bit of every stock in
the economy, no matter how small, no
matter how big, no matter how safe,
no matter how risky you should
spread your money across everything.
That's the recommendation of Tobin and
it relies of course on everybody else
being rational. So everybody
else is choosing the right thing.
Then you can just piggy back and do
what everybody else is doing. Okay.
So that's the first thing. Very
shocking. As I said, at first glance,
you'd think someone who is loves risk
would just invest in risky stocks and
people who's very people very risk averse.
When just invest in safe stocks,
Tobin says, no, no, no, no. If you're
very risk tolerant or risk averse,
you should just put most of your money
in the bank and hold a little bit of
every stock. So you're here somewhere.
If you're very risk tolerant,
you shouldn't just
concentrate on the risky,
you should buy the same proportion
of also stocks as everyone else.
But you should borrow the money to do it.
And maybe way up here and people
who borrow money to invest.
That's called leveraging.
Okay.
So that's idea number one,
the crucial idea and a lot of
ideas mixed in that. And as I said,
you can test it by seeing if everyone
could be, anyone can beat the market.
Is there anyone who historically has hired
a higher sharp ratio than the market?
And,
and in 1967,
when all this was being tested, you
know, there was a famous book called, um,
a random walk down Wall
Street written by Matthew,
Walk Down Wall Street,
which I recommend you read a random
walk down Wall Street in which people,
he gives the history of tests of whether
people could beat the market. Of course,
many people beat the market
for short periods of time,
then they totally collapsed.
And uh,
and then some people beat the market
for 20 years in a row and then retire.
But there are so few of those
people that it looks like, you know,
but just by random dumb luck,
you could get almost those people.
On the other hand,
there's some people like Warren Buffett
who seem to beat the market for 40 or 50
years. It's really hard to believe
that that's all just luck. And uh,
so that's one test of the thing.
Then the second idea of the capital
asset pricing model is risk and return.
And so now if we assume,
so all this graph by the way
assumed quadratic utilities,
quadratic where mean variants,
utilities, quadratic utility.
And a common probabilities.
So everybody knew what the probabilities
were, the different states.
So you know how to measure the covariance
and the variants and all that cause
you know what the probabilities
are to measure over. So here, uh,
having assume that it turns out that
you just apply the principle that we saw
the first few days of class,
that the price is going to
equal the marginal utility.
Hey, not the total utility price
is going to equal margin utility.
And if the price equals
the marginal utility,
the Margie utility is
going to be, uh, depends.
According to this assumption of quadratic
utilities as we showed depends on
expectation.
So this is the price of y.
Let's just call it pie of why.
Like I did before. Okay. It
depends on the expectation of why,
and it depends on the covariance.
Oh,
why with the market.
Okay.
So it doesn't depend on
the W we've assumed with
quadratic utilities that people
only care about the mean and the variance.
So you would have expected don't the
margin utility of any single asset to
depend on its mean and its variance.
But it's the marginal utility.
It's what it adds to
what you've already got.
So it adds expectation
because expectations additive.
But when you add another stock
to what you already have,
the variants of the whole portfolio
changes according to the covariants of the
new thing with what you already had and
everybody already had the market. Okay.
So given that you know that
the price mathematically,
therefore the price has to equal
something times the expectation of y plus
something times the covariance
of why with the market.
Okay.
But that's true for all why in particular?
It's true for the riskless acids.
So the riskless asset pays one for sure,
has no covariance with anything like
the market and its price is one over one
plus r. So therefore a has
to be one over one plus r.
So we know that this has to be one plus
r and then okay be could be whatever it
is, the covariance, by the way, it's going
to be bad. So this is minus and then B,
you have to figure be out those loans.
So you don't know what B is. A Priori,
even though at the interest rate is
either, you had to see that in the market.
Once you know the price of one asset
and you know it's correlation with the
market.
If you knew this price and you know
the expectation of why and you know the
Coburn's with the market that will tell
you being so once you've given one price
of a risky asset,
like of the market as a whole,
you're going to be able to figure
out the price of every other asset.
Cause from that one price you can
deduce B. And once you have be,
you can price everything. So that's
the second idea of risk and return.
And you can see it graphically
and more dramatically.
Because if I take that same equation,
this is called the
covariance pricing formula.
You take that and divide by Pi of why
you get one equals expectation of y
divided by the price of y dividing
both sides by Pi of y minus B times the
covariance of y over the
price of y with them.
Okay?
And that.
So that just tells me the expectation
and the covariance of a dollar's worth,
just like this was a dollar's worth. This
was per dollar and this is per dollar.
So if you put the covariance of why and
the Pi of lie down here and Ammo for
here and here,
you put expectation why over pie of why
this just says this is just a constant,
and this is a constant. So it says
this and this are linearly related.
These are all securities
would have priced one.
There has to be a linear relationship
between their expectation for dollar in
their covariance per dollar with the
market. And as the covariance gets higher,
the return gets higher.
So only people,
so if you take a stock
with a high covariance,
it's going to have to have
a high expected return.
That's exactly what Shakespeare said.
If it's more risky,
people won't hold it unless
it's got a higher return,
which means you can buy
it for a cheap price.
So it's price is less than
it's expectation. But the,
the difference with Shakespeare
is we've quantified risk.
It's not what you would've thought.
Variance. It's covariance and that's it.
Those are the two big ideas.
And you could test,
so this is called the
security market line.
Okay.
And you could test this
by asking is every stock.
So if you look at every stock last year,
you look at it's covariance,
you put a point here, then you look
this year at its expected return,
of course some stocks
are going to be wild,
but you average over a bunch of
stocks and a bunch of years, you know,
do you get things that why in a straight
line or close to a straight line and
sharp in 1967 found that amazingly
when you did that you got,
so I described last night
exactly what his task was.
You got something that looked incredibly
close to a straight line like that.
So this was the greatest triumph in
the history of the social sciences.
It was called because you had huge
amounts of data, huge, you know,
capacity to test things. A shocking
conclusion, a shockingly precise,
you know, theory, the test and it
fit the line so incredibly closely.
And it, it just swept. Uh,
it made a huge impression and financing
and Economics and lots of Nobel prizes
were given for the sharp won a Nobel
prize mark, which won a Nobel prize.
Tobin won a Nobel Prize winner died.
He would have won a Nobel
prize too. Um, okay,
so this was the first
major triumph of fine,
the most important trying to find for
the capital asset pricing model. Now,
as it happens, as the theory has
been tested over and over again,
every year since 1967,
it's performed more and more poorly.
And so now when you do this,
you get points that looked like this
and like that and like this, and they,
they don't seem to lie on a,
on a straight line at all.
And it's pretty shocking how up until 67
or the early seventies and seem to work
out perfectly and now it
doesn't work very well. Okay.
And the Markowitz and this business,
they've also discovered according to this,
you know, you couldn't
beat the market. Okay.
So how do you test whether
something beats the market?
You can pick a bunch of people and say,
could they beat the market?
Or you can actually just make up a
strategy yourself like by only new stocks
just every year by the stocks that are
come on to the s and p 500 for the first
time.
Or just buy the stocks that are the
biggest 10% and it turns out some of those
strategies actually do beat the market.
So I don't have time to go into the
details, you know, that is, they lie, uh,
above or below here. So the theories
coming too. So theory and doubt.
And so what I'm going to
talk about next week is,
and it certainly doesn't explain
the current crisis. Okay.
So want next week to explain crisis.
So next week I'm going to end
by giving a counter theory,
another theory, which is, you know,
going to explain the crisis
and be different from this one.
But of course it hasn't been
tested over 30 years or 50 years.
Like KPM KPM look great
for the first 20 years.
So whatever I say next week we'll
probably turn out to be 90% wrong.
But at the moment it looks pretty good
and I didn't want to spend half the
course on it in case in 20 years and
seem to be ridiculous. But anyway,
I'm going to present it anyway to those
of you who want to hear it, um, next week.
And there'll be,
I think,
understandable and down to earth and
it will invoke a very basic thing.
Nowhere in this model that we
take into account, you know,
when we say people leverage,
that means they're borrowing
money and choosing to go up here.
We haven't taken into account,
um,
that they're gonna have to pay the money
back and who's going to trust them to
pay the money back and forcing them to
do something to guarantee they're going
to take pay the money back is going to
change the theory in a critical way,
which I'll get to next week. Okay. Now,
one last thing about the theory. Um,
as I say,
you test it by seeing nobody should be
above this line and nobody should be
above this line. But of course you
can find people above this line.
Swenson to take a famous yell
examples above this line.
And you can find people above this line.
Ellington.
So Ellington, let's say above this
line. All right, so what a hedge funds,
let's just call it an anonymous hedge
funds since we're on camera now.
Hedge Fund Hedge Fund II. Okay. Above.
So the question is, is
that luck, you know,
they just did it a few
years in both cases,
like 15 years a piece or is it just or
is it, does it mean something? All right,
well, so you can measure the Co, you know,
if you believe this theory
and you just say, okay,
let's say the theory is 99% true,
it's just that there are a few
people who really do beat the market,
then you can decide by looking
at these graphs, you know,
just how good is Swenson
relative to the market.
How good is this hedge fund
relative to the market and a,
so you have a way of calibrating
and measuring how well people do.
So I don't have time to get into that.
But I would measure the quality of a
hedge fund by its marginal Sharpe ratio.
How much does having
access to this hedge fund,
if you added it to your portfolio,
increase your portfolio hedge ratio.
That's I think the right measure
of how good a hedge fund is.
And the right measure of how good
Swinson is is what's the sharp ratio.
And so there's a different criteria,
and I keep emphasizing this Swenson
is managing an entire portfolio.
So you have to measure him on
housing done free, Gail, you don't,
not because yells not going to
combine him with something else.
It's just holding what he holds. So
it's his sharp ratio. But Ellington,
you're going to combine,
Ellington was some other stuff.
So Swenson might invest in Ellington,
but 10 million other things.
And so you have to say, how is Ellington
gonna help Swenson's Sharpe ratio?
So instead of Swinson Sharpe ratio,
how much is Ellington going to
help the market Sharpe ratio?
So that's how you should
measure a hedge fund.
It's marginal Sharpe ratio and,
and uh,
Swenson by these, his sharp
ratio. Okay. So I'd say, you know,
um, measure Swenson, performance
Swenson performance,
my Sharpe ratio
ain't measure hedge fund
performance by marginal Sharpe ratio
because you'd be crazy to put all your
money in a
hedge fund.
The only people who do it are the
partners of the hedge fund who are sort of
forced to do it because that's all they
can persuade investors that they're
really paying attention to their fund
because all their money's at risk. But um,
okay, so that's it. That's
the basic bottom line.
So there any questions before
I now move on from this?
Okay.
We talked about this last night,
we've talked about it for the
last two lectures. All right.
So it's a high watermark,
as I say,
incredibly precise prediction
and incredibly close to
the facts at least in 1967
but on that, not after
that. Now I want them,
I moved to an aside of social security
before I come back to black shoals,
which is the next high water, the last
high watermark of the standard theory.
So [inaudible] remember the upshot
of what we've talked about so far,
the upshot of this is that,
um,
the market,
we'll get a higher return.
Oh, by the way, I just
say one other thing.
What is the standard
critique of this theory?
So of course everybody else is seeing
that the theory doesn't work. So what is,
what is their explanation for why,
what's the old explanation for why
the theory isn't working so well?
Now the explanation is
that in the old days,
what was thought of as the market
was just all American stocks.
But now it's pretty obvious.
In fact,
it should have been
obvious from the beginning.
And so Swenson realized
that early on that mark,
what's his advice is to
diversify, diversify, diversify,
not just into all American stocks,
into everything all over the world and
all kinds of assets that are in stocks at
all. So what you measure as the market
shouldn't just be American stocks.
It should be the world portfolio. But
how do you measure the world portfolio?
That's hard to do.
And so people have tried to maintain that.
The reason the theory doesn't work is
because we've got the wrong m in all these
equations.
Okay?
So that would be a nice
way of fixing the theory.
I doubt if that's going to help in the
end. So my problem about collaterals,
a different look at it,
but anyhow,
so the market according to the theory
will get a higher return. Okay.
Then bonds and of course that's true.
And the market has a very high
positive covariance with itself.
So very low price up here,
it's high covariance with itself.
So a low price compared to its
expectation, the prices low.
So you're paying much less
than the expectations.
So then when you see
what actually happens,
it's going to look much higher than that.
It's going to be the racial, you know,
it's not just this, the price
is lower, therefore the, the,
the final outcome's going to be
much bigger on average. Okay.
So to put it another way,
if you had two possibilities,
which you knew were equally likely a half
and a half, and the market, you know,
paid off good, something good
here and something bad here.
Okay. So everybody's rich here
and everybody's poor here.
The price of the Arrow security of this
state is going to be much lower than the
price of the Earl security of this state.
This state is going to have a price,
you know, uh, let's say 0.8, and this
one might have a price point too,
because here the bad state,
that's when everybody's poor.
So you're going to,
you know,
this formula basically tells you
that if you're paying off here,
you're negatively
correlated with the market.
You're going to have to pay a very high
price for it because you're hedging,
you know, by buying this
security or balancing off, uh,
what you have with the market by
buying the market, your, you know,
your,
um,
people don't like that because it adds
more risk to what you already have.
And so the price of this is going,
people don't like,
it's not going to pay very much of the
price will be much less than the actual
probability of a half. Okay.
So I want to now, all right,
so that's the conclusion
of what we've done.
I want to now connect
this to social security.
So you remember in our
social security model,
we had land that went here, here, here,
you know, paid one, one, one, one, one.
And we had these people overlap
in generations. People like that.
Okay?
And we discovered a very important thing.
The reason why social security seems to
be broke is because we gave away so much
money to the people in
the first generation.
It's not that social security wastes
money like George Bush seems to imply
whenever he talks about it,
it's not like they just throw it away.
It's that we gave a huge
gift to the people in the
forties, the 50s and the 60s.
And so everyone after that has to
pay for that, uh, pay for that gift.
But there's a little bit more to George
Bush a story then I'm allowed so far,
which is that he doesn't,
he wants to put the money into stocks and
we know that stocks are going to get a
higher return than bonds. Okay?
That's the whole point of this theory.
He put money in stocks.
The expected return on stocks is higher
than the expected return on bonds.
So if you want to make this mathematical,
we have to add the possibility of risk
and stocks and it looks like it's going
to be complicated, but we can do it
very easily. So I'm going to just put,
I'm going to reproduce the same picture
with uncertainty and stocks in it.
And then we're going to come back to
social security and spend 15 minutes
talking about, uh, what, what's
the right plan for social security?
So how could I make this,
how could I take the simple model,
which already seemed complicated,
it's already pretty complicated model,
had no uncertainty and I'll
put uncertainty in it. Okay,
well I'm going to suppose that land,
okay,
so this is the land dividends
I'm now going to describe.
And by the way, I had people
with endowments here, they
were three one and three.
One,
remember this is their endowments,
but we didn't say where
those endowments came from.
So I'm going to take the land dividends.
I'm going to suppose the dividend,
the land today is one.
But you know,
things might get better
or worse in the future.
Maybe the dividend goes to
two or down to a half. Say,
you know, I'm taking some extreme
case where it doubles are halves.
And maybe after that it could double again
or it could go back to one and here I
could go to one or could go to a corner.
So you know,
what dividends are doing is a,
is a random walk.
If the economy starts getting more
productive, um, you know, then,
then it's in a better position.
And from that point things
get even more productive.
Or maybe go back to where they were. If
things get worse, you know, they're worse,
but maybe things will start to get
better again or continue to get worse.
So this is what I imagine
as my process of dividends.
Okay?
So if you own the land,
you get all these dividends
in the whole infinite future.
All right? And now let's say
that there's labor as well.
So labor incomes, I have to make
an assumption about labor income.
Okay?
So I'm going to assume only young word.
So here are, we kind of made
the same assumption. You know,
you get a lot when you're young
and not much when you're old.
I'm gonna assume only the young work
and I'm going to assume that this
productivity gains or losses you don't,
by the way,
you might think you never go backwards.
Maybe it goes from one
to two or one to 1.1.
So it's always growing but never,
but you know, but but random.
But I'm just going to keep it here
since I solve this example. Yeah,
last night I might as well stick to that
one, but there's no reason why I quit.
I could have made the thing
always no matter what,
get either stay the same or get better.
That might've been a better example to
do a more realistic because we don't
really have tremendous productivity
declines. Um, but anyway,
all by mean to do is to
put some randomness here.
So only young work and wages
a proportional to dividends.
So let's just assume this,
so I'm assuming this is,
this is what's called a
neutral technical change.
So presumably the reason why productivity
is going up the dividends or getting
high or is there more discoveries
improving the product of the land,
but they're probably also
improving the product of labor.
And so let's say they have
the same effect on both.
So I'm going to assume that Labor is
actually what the one above, let's uh,
okay.
Let's, uh, say Labor always gets
three times with dividends are,
so this is a six.
This will be three halves and this
will be 12 and three again and three
quarters.
That's what Labor is getting.
So labor income shouldn't
know switch colors, labor
income.
Okay.
So that's my complicated world.
Way more complicated than it was before.
So if you own the land,
you get all the dividends in the future.
People live two periods.
So I'm going to assume that utility.
So you're going to be,
you're going to live when you're young
and then when you're old and up and we
are old in down. Okay. So you
know you're going to live,
let's say a guy born here, he's
young here, she's young here,
she can work here or she can. Um, and
then she's going to be old here in here.
But when she's old, it's not clear how
good her investment is going to turn out.
So this is going to
just be our simple log.
I'll call this a half log.
Y lost a quarter log,
Z up plus of quarter,
log z down.
Okay,
so you don't discount the future.
Let's say you just take log of
consumption today plus a half, you know,
probability,
a half of log consumption,
the upstate half log and
consumption of the downstate.
So the probabilities here are a half.
These are the objective probabilities.
Okay?
So maybe I should have written
that utility. Maybe better.
It would have been to write
the utility like that. Hey,
that's what people know what the
probabilities are. Okay, so that's it.
That's my setup.
So what should the economy do? What
should people do? You see, if you buy,
you know, if you're a,
some person like this lady,
when here she could,
um,
she could decide to hold bonds and she
could get whatever the interest rate
turns out to be,
which we're going to compute in a minute.
Or she could hold stock,
in which case she's going to get,
let's start her off here.
Maybe she could buy land.
Okay, buy stock now.
We don't want the prices yet. We have to
compute that. But if she buys the stock,
she'll get a dividend of two here and be
able to sell the land for a high price
because from here on, it's obviously
pretty better than it was back here.
Or she might get unlucky and
the price might, you know,
the dividend might be really terrible,
just a half. And not only that,
but the land she sells when she's old is
also going to have a really lousy price.
So she holds land,
she's going to get a high dividend or
a high capital return or else a low
dividend, a low capital return.
It's really risky for her.
Or she could just buy a bond at whatever
interest rate it turns out to be and
get some things safe. So what
should she do? And, and uh,
you know,
will that be a good thing for the economy
or can we make everybody better off by
him by using social security?
So how can we solve this?
Okay, so it looks like a
really complicated model
to Saul because we've got a
generation born here,
another one born here,
the same generation might be born up
here under different circumstances.
And then this generation here,
it could be born under any three different
circumstances the way they do the lot
to solve for.
But what we know is that when we compute
the Arrow price starting from any
point, this arrow price is
going to be bigger than I have.
And this one's going to be less than a
half because the economy is, you know,
doing much worse down here.
And so people know they're all going to
get screwed down here and consume a lot
less. So to hedge that,
they're all gonna want to buy,
they're going to be desperate
to buy consumption down here.
Of course they can't all do that.
So it's gotta be the price that's more
than a half that discourages them from
doing that.
And they don't really need that much
to buy up here because you know their
dividends, you know they're
going to be so rich anyway.
So the price there are security is
going to be less, uh, it, you know,
is going to be a less than a half because
there's so much that they have to end
up holding and that'll encourage
them to Dubai. I mean, sorry,
I said the logic backwards.
There's so much that they're going to
hand off to end up consuming because the
economy is so productive.
How can you get them to plan
to consume that much up there?
It's by having a low Errol security price.
So in even an advance,
they know that they're going to end up
consuming a lot and they're happy to do
that because they're willing to buy or
sell securities because they're so cheap.
Okay, so how, how do we solve all this?
So everybody following the problem,
it's quite a complicated problem,
but it's turns out to have
a very simple answer. Yep.
Price of consumption is
high,
but the price of land is low.
Yes.
Right. So well. So if you start
starting from here,
the price of consult,
if you want to buy at this point,
consumption at this point,
you're going to have to pay
more than a half to get it.
But you know that once you get here, the
price of land is going to have dropped.
So yes,
I'm agreeing with you
Kevin,
right now, why should the price of
land be lower here? Because here,
so remember the price of land is
always in terms of the new Martin,
the consumption. Good. That period,
every period I might as well take
an apple to be have a price of one.
So you'll see APP,
the land here is producing an entire
apple and on average going forward,
you know it's going to
be producing one apple.
The geometric average of all these
numbers is one starting at this point.
Once you've gone down to here,
production has deteriorated.
The land is only producing half
an apple here. And in the future,
instead of reducing 12 it's going to
produce three apples here and only three
quarters on happening.
So it's crummy or land down here.
So you're going to pay less for the
land. Okay? Any other questions?
But I'm going to tell you exactly
what you'll pay for the land.
So we're going to solve this.
So need to solve
for land price
in each state
and
um,
interest rate.
Okay.
At each state
and
price of up Arielle security
and price
down Arielle security
at each state.
So how can we do all
that? Well, first of all,
you notice that the Arrow
securities are always the key.
Once you solve for those,
you can figure out everything else.
So we just have to solve for these,
the price of the up and down arrows,
securities in every state.
Oh,
this was me in a previous class today.
I didn't erase it. I figured the next
guy wouldn't do it. Serves me. Right.
Okay.
Okay. So how can we solve this? Well,
we can guess.
Yes,
let's do appear. Yes. That,
um,
these prices,
Arielle prices
the same
at every state.
Okay. So what do you, what I mean by that?
I mean here, how many apples would
you pay to get an apple here?
I'm guessing that that's the same amount
you would pay here to get an apple here.
Okay.
And then what you would pay an apple at
this point to get an apple down here is
going to be the same as this generation
would pay to get an apple down here.
There's a lot that's a guest. We have
to verify that that's going to work.
It seems like everything's sort of home
genius.
And so guess
that price of land
lamb is proportional to dividends.
The dividends
in that state.
Okay, well the whole thing is sort
of homogeneous and everything.
So you know the land here is four
times as good as the land here.
The land here is four times as good as
the land here because the dividends are
always four times higher if you go up
one thing. So this is four times that,
that's four times that.
So why not guessed that the price of
land is four times here than it is here
four times higher here than it
is here. Sounds possible. Anyway.
And of course these are going to
turn out to be correct guesses.
So once you make these guesses,
it's going to be very simple to find the
equilibrium and then we can verify that
the guest is are correct.
Okay.
So what does this guy want to do here?
So assume you only work when you're young.
So what's your income?
What's anybody's income
like this young guy here?
Young at time.
At time one.
So this is time one here.
It's time to time. Three time
four. So yeah, Taiwan, their income
income is three
because that's what their wage was.
They work when they're young and
they've got three. That's it.
They don't own the land. When they're
born, they're going to buy the land,
but they don't own it now.
Okay.
What do they want to do?
They want to consume when they're
young or utility where member.
So what's their budget set?
Your budget said is they
can consume why that's
consuming here, where they
can consume here. Here. Okay.
But so they can consume,
uh, p, uh,
up times Z up plus p down Timesi down.
That's what they can do with
Oh zero securities. So, um,
what are they trying to make
surmise?
They're trying to maximize one half
log y plus one quarter log z up
plus one quarter logs.
He there.
That's what they're trying to do.
Okay, so now what do they have
to, what do we have to do?
We have to clear market in this market
given what the young are going to do in
the next period. But let's see what
this guy's going to do when he's young.
Everybody's going to face a similar,
basically a scaled up
version of this problem.
So this is what the guy's doing here.
He's got an income of three and
there's the price of up and down arrows
securities that's going to tell them what
to consume here and what they consume.
Plan to consume up here and down here.
Sure.
So utility function is the same one as
this I just multiplied through by a half,
right? So I put a half a quarter, a
quarter to get that. So that's the same,
I'm just multiplied it all by a constant.
Okay,
so now the coefficients add up to
one a half, a quarter and a quarter.
So what is the guy who,
that's his budget constraints.
But what's the budget constraint
going to be of a guy down here?
It's exactly the same.
He's going to maximize the same utility
function and as budget constraint is
since the prices of the Arrow security,
so the same,
the only difference is going to be
that he's only got three halves here.
Okay,
so they're pretty similar problems.
So let's see what the guy at time
one is going to do. That's going to
ply that y equals Cobb dog
was a half times his income.
Three divided by the price of y,
which is just one what?
Half of three over one,
which is three halves.
Yes.
Okay.
And what's he going to do when he's old?
Z up is going to be while is Cobb dog.
This is a quarter.
Okay.
And then his income
still three and then the price is p up
of the ERL security and won the down
case.
He's going to have a porter times three.
That's his income divided by p down.
Okay,
so to clear this market,
what do we have to do?
We have to clear the market by
doing what? Z up. That's this guy.
So one quarter.
So this is the old guy
times three divided by p up.
That's what this guy wants to consume
up here plus what the young are going to
do there. But we know what the
younger going to do here. This guy,
this young person is doing exactly what
this guy did except instead of having a
starting well for three as
a starting wealth of six,
so instead of consuming young three house,
he's going to consume young six halves.
So this is going to be plus three
he's going to consume half of his wages
just like this guy consumed half of his
way just when he was young. So
this old, this new young guy,
the young guys are always going to
consume in the first period half of what
their wages are. That's what this equation
tells us. If this is your budget set,
this is your income,
this is what your budget said is,
and this is what you're maximizing.
This is very special Cobb
Douglas Case where you have
endowments only in one good.
So it's clear that in that good
you'll always consume the Cobb.
Doug was coefficient fraction of it,
a half of that.
So three halves and this guy's going to
consume a half of six which is three so
the old appear are going
to consume that number.
The younger going to consume three and
what's the total that's available for
them to consume?
What's available?
No more
eight but the young got six apples and
the de Lyon paid to apples in dividends.
So the total number of apples is eight
so that's it.
And so we can solve that.
And that's going to imply that multiplying
that's five and multiplying by four
is 20 so p you,
so I'm going to screw this up now.
P you is three over 20
yeah.
Okay.
Because if you put three over 20 in here,
you get the threes cancel and you get
20 over four which is five and five plus
three is eight so it's three over 20 now,
meanwhile what are we going to have
in the upstate, in the upstate,
downstate. That was the
upstate. In the downstate.
MMM,
no, in the downstate. The
guy's going to do one quarter,
three over PD. Okay. What is
this other guy going to do?
The young person here
is going to consume what
reigns on the downstate. What are we going
to have the equation on the downstate?
Okay,
it's going to be,
so this one,
one order three divided by p down.
Plus,
what's the,
what's this guy going to
consume when he's young? Well,
his income is wages are three halves
and he's going to consume half of that.
So it's three quarters.
All right?
Because when you're young,
you always end up consuming half of your,
of your wages. So three quarters and
that has to equal, what's the total?
Two.
Okay, so what does that leave us?
That leaves us three quarters.
That's five fourths.
So let's see.
So five fourths equals
three quarters over PD.
So PD is going to equal three fifths.
All right?
Cause the forest out and put PD
up on the five down. It's three
fifths. So that's it. So now we've got,
we figured out the prices.
So this Arrow security was a half and I'm,
the probabilities are half half.
But the prices,
the Arrow security prices are going to
be less than a half in more than a half.
Forgot what they were already.
Three 20th
three over 20 and three over
five those are the aero prices.
By the way, you noticed they don't add
up to one. So what's the interest rate?
So if you want to get a riskless bond
pays one in each of these two states.
So how much is that worth?
One over one plus r equals you
have to buy both Errol securities.
We've done this before.
Three 20th plus three fifths,
which equals 15 20th equals three fours.
So therefore one plus
r equals four thirds.
So it's ours is 33%
okay. So that's when we did,
we've got the probabilities,
three 20th and three fifths justice.
We thought the price of the down Arrow
security is going to be much bigger than
the price of the apparel security.
Even though objectively they have
50 50 probability. And why is that?
Because everyone who's rational is going
to realize that they have to plan to
consume much more up here than down here.
But they're not going to want to do
that unless the price is much cheaper.
Okay? So that's how we got the price.
And now what's the price of land?
That's the only last thing
we have to figure out.
So the price of land.
So the price of land at
time one equals what?
Well, what if you buy
the land? What do you get
with?
You get three 20th then you
get the dividend, which is too,
but then you get to sell the land,
which just p uh,
land up.
Okay. And then plus if you get
the downstate, you get a dividend.
So the downstate has is
worth three fifths to you,
right? And then what do you
get? What's your dividend?
A half plus the price of the
land you can sell p laying down.
Okay, so that's what the
price of land is it one.
It depends of course on what you can
sell the plant price of land for in the
future.
But we made a guess here that the price
of land is just proportional to the
price of, of the, uh, dividend.
So whenever the price of land is here,
when the dividend is one,
it should be twice as high here and
half as high here. So therefore,
this instead of looking at
is the price of land went up,
it's going to be the price twice. The
price of land was at the very beginning.
So it's just two times the price of land
at the beginning times that same price.
And this price of winded
down the dividends half.
So the land is sort of half as good from
here on out as it was in the beginning.
So let's guess the price of land is
half of what it was at the beginning.
Yeah.
Okay. But now you see we've just got p
land in terms of other stuff and so we can
solve for it.
So the price of land
is going to equal,
well now it's complicated.
So three tens
plus three tens times
the price of land plus,
um,
three tens
plus three tens times the price of land.
Okay.
And so that means the price of land
minus six 10 so four times four tenths,
the price of one
lan
is going to equal six tens.
So the price of land is three
halves at the beginning.
Yeah.
Okay. So we figured out the price
of land here. Price of land,
price of land is three halves
at the very beginning. Okay.
So we've saw for the whole equilibrium,
it took a long time. But I'm, I'm in,
I'm at the end of the story now. Um,
so let's just review what we did. Okay.
And so I don't think it's
that complicated a story.
The story is that you've got
land which has risky dividends.
So instead of having one straight
line of what can happen in the future,
we've got this infinitely expanding tree.
So it's very hard to imagine solving it.
But then we've built in so
much special assumptions,
we've got all this homogeneous and that
allows us to solve it because it's the
same problem getting repeated over and
over again, just like we did before.
So the price of land turns
out to be three halves.
So what is this guy going to do?
Okay,
he's going to take his land,
his income,
which is three eat half of it,
which was three halves.
That's what we said he
always does when he's young.
Spent half the consumption
halfers income on consumption,
the rest of his income, three
halves. He used to buy all the land.
Now with the land,
he gets a pay off of two.
Okay buddy gets to sell the land.
Now for double the price,
he bought it mainly for three.
So two plus three is five and that,
by the way,
the price of up was three
20th so this is five right?
Cause I put in three 20th some here.
That's the Arrow price of opt and Z up
is going to be five and so that's exactly
how we got it with the land.
He gets the dividend of two plus he
sells the land for three. That's five.
So he does consume five z down.
Incidentally,
the price of down was three fifths.
Okay,
so the consumption of down,
what's consumption of down?
I'm going to be
five. Four, thank you. Price,
there'll be five. Four.
So let's say that that's going to work
out too. So the guy buys the land,
he gets his dividend of a half,
and then he sells the land
for half of this price,
which is three quarters and a half,
plus three quarters is five for us exactly
what we supposed to have. So you see,
it works out that everybody's
doing exactly what they're
supposed to in all the
markets are clearing.
Anyhow,
the point is not so much the numbers.
The point is the following that
sure enough, just as we said before,
the price of Arrow securities are going
to be expensive when things are going
down and cheap when things are going up.
The upshot of that is the return on on
stocks like land is going to be very
high. You put in three halves, okay,
what happens with the three
halves with probability a half?
That's what you put in with probability
a half, you get two plus three or five,
you get a, you get to, plus you get to
sell the land for three, which is five.
And with the other probability a
half, you get to the, the, the, uh,
dividends is a half,
plus you sell the land for three quarters,
that's what you're eating. Five and
five floors, that's equal to, you know,
five halves plus, um, plus five,
force plus five. I don't know what
this is. Five forest, what is this?
One half plus three quarters is five.
Four turns a half. It's five eighths,
okay. Divided by three halves.
So this is a very high number.
So what is this four times that,
that's 25 over eight 25 over
eight divided by three over two,
which is, uh, it's what?
25 over 12?
Is that what you said?
Okay.
25 over 12 and just believing in out,
okay,
so that is over 200%,
right?
So your return is 100% whatever you,
whatever you put in,
you more than doubled
your money in expectation.
Whereas the interest rate we said
was 33 and a third percent. Okay?
So of course you're getting a tremendous
return by putting your money into
capital because that's the whole point
of the theory. You're going, it's risky.
The whole economy is going to, you
know, be rich or poor together.
So they're going to the price
of capital on the margin.
It's a very risky thing to do.
It just adds to this
inequality in your consumption.
So the price is going to be low,
you're going to get a very high return.
That's all I want it to do.
I just solved it out concretely.
So you can see very clearly that you get
a high return in the good state and uh,
you get a high return on capital, much
higher than the riskless rate of interest.
So there we are, we're back at the
beginning now where George Bush,
we can see that somewhere in the middle
here, things are really disastrous.
These people who are
getting social security,
which means they're getting a fixed amount
here in here, are doing really badly,
at least an expected return compared to
what they would do in the stock market.
Okay.
And so what should
we do about that? And is it true that, um,
just because stocks make a higher return,
it's a,
we should privatized. So
what do you think now? Where,
where are we in this argument?
Has Anything materially changed?
Okay.
So George Bush is saying,
and many Republicans say that we should,
we should let people, you know,
get them invested in stocks.
There's a higher expected return.
So what do we think about that?
What do you think about that?
Okay.
And this is a real policy issue here.
We've got this problem in America
right now. We've got this huge deficit.
And in social security,
you know,
the rate of return is gotten
really poor for your generation.
You're looking forward to
not making very much money.
And now we know theoretically
confirming what we seen in the past,
stocks are making higher
returns than bonds.
And social security is paying people
a fraction of the wages of the young.
And uh, you know, so what do we, you know,
so let me remind you the arguments.
So,
but the issue has come up because
social security is running out of money.
So it came up because of this problem.
You know there's going to be a deficit
if we continue to pay people the same
rules that we've used up until now,
we're not going to be able to
afford to do it much longer.
So we're going to have to lower what we
pay the the people going forward or else
differ in a lower,
in some clever way.
Like they don't get money till they're
older instead of 65 way make them wait
till 70 or do something
like that to pay them less.
That's one way of balancing things and
the reason and because we're going to
have to make changes like that.
That's why the whole issue
of social security's come
up and we've now, you know,
deeper thinkers are questioning
the whole idea of social security.
So let me just remind you that America
was ahead of everyone in the world.
When we created social security under
Roosevelt, nobody had anything like it.
Then everybody in the US rest of the
world gradually copied us and now
everybody's facing the
same problem we are,
which we know why you have to face it.
You're giving away stuff to the people.
At the beginning.
And so they're facing it by changing
social security in some crazy way or
another. And we haven't changed anything
at all. But obviously we have to,
and my question is how should we change
it and what's the right thing to do?
And just to remind you again of the issues
the Democrats and Republicans seem to
be totally opposed to each other.
The Democrats say,
Oh, we want to, you know,
continue to give people who have done
poorly in their lives a better deal on
social security because we
want, we want to, uh, you know,
we want to redistribute, we want to
help the poor. The Republicans actually,
some of them agree with that, but some of
them don't agree with that. But anyway,
even the ones who agreed,
that's not the most important thing.
They think of what in social security.
Then the Democrats say social security
is so important because, you know,
we're sharing risks across generation.
We don't want, uh, you know,
if the next generation has poor wages.
So they ended up down here with bad wages,
you know,
the economy takes a turn
south with bad wages.
Then the old people should
suffer along with them.
And if the young do better
with high wages cause thing,
what's went up then like the old
should also get better social security
dividends. And that's what the current
situation promises. Okay. The, um,
the, uh, it's also indexed according to
inflation. All right? So once you retire,
then you're protected
against changes in inflation.
And then another important
thing of Democrats,
you don't have an opportunity
to make a mistake.
If you invest in stocks and
stuff like that, you know,
in the stock market suddenly collapses.
You're not going to lose money in
social security because social security
depends on the wage of
the next generation.
And that moves much slower than the stock.
Okay.
The Republicans on the other hand
say, you know, this is just terrible.
Nobody knows what their property
rights are in social security.
No one actually understands how much
money they're getting when they're old.
They just know now it's going to be bad.
And it compared to what they're paying
in taxes, but they don't even know.
You don't even know what it is.
So how can that be good? And, uh,
so it's not transparent and not only that,
whatever you think it is now,
it's going to turn out to be worse because
in 10 years somebody's going to say
all the systems not balanced.
We have to, you know,
delay benefits or something to put it
back into balance and we're going to take
away what you thought you were going to
get. So Republicans say that's horrible.
Nobody knows really exactly what it is.
And they get an idea of what it
might be and then they always,
but it can always be taken away.
Okay.
Really what they want to know is what's
the value of my social security account
and I want it to be mine. And then, uh,
I can also then tell what the
redistribution is. You know,
if I know what I'm paying in taxes and I
know that the value of the benefits I'm
getting, I can see that my taxes
are much more than my benefits.
And if I happen to be a nice guy
and think it's a good idea to have
redistribution, fine. But if I'm
a bad, you know, not a bad guy.
If I just don't believe in
that much redistribution,
I should be aware of it and have
the chance to vote against it. Okay.
And also a key thing is these
Republicans say people should get equity,
like returns, not this wages in the
next generation. Those grows slowly.
Stocks might have a much higher return.
On average,
people should get equity like returns.
So let's put them in the stock market.
And then Republicans think
choice is always great. You know,
even if people make mistakes, it's their
own mistakes. So let them make mistakes.
So those are the opposite
sides of the argument.
They seem totally at odds with each
other and impossible to reconcile.
So I want to now tell my plan of rec.
So everyone's got the problem straight.
We're running out of money and the
philosophies of the two groups seem to be
totally opposed. So what should
we do about it? All right,
so my plan in five minutes because
I want to end with black shoals,
my plan in five minutes is
mmm,
okay. To make a few
observations. First of all, yes,
it's true that you get a
higher return on stocks,
then you get on bonds,
but you face a higher risk.
So it's not like you get it for free. It's
a, you know, it's a bigger risk. And so,
um, okay, so that's number one.
So you don't actually number 0.0 is
you still got the problem because you,
you gave money to all those people in
the forties and the 50s and the 60s and
the 70s that money's gone. We
have to something, you know,
we've essentially borrowed to give them
money and somebody's got to pay back
that debt.
And so there's no way around that.
There's this huge $17 trillion
debt hanging out there
that we have to pay back.
And you can't get around that.
So putting the money into equities
or wherever you put the money,
there's still that tremendous debt.
Now the question is,
so you can't just make the problem go
away by saying that equities have a higher
return. Stocks also have, I mean,
bonds also have a higher return than
the return people are getting on social
security because the social
security return includes
the tax that you're paying,
you know, to, to make up for the
original generation. So, okay,
so that's the first thing.
So the next thing is, um,
maybe it's not such a big difference,
you know, this equities and not equities,
because notice in this model
you don't,
when the stock is paying higher on the
stock dividends or higher two instead of
one, the price of stocks goes up. That's
a great return from the stock market.
But the wages were also higher
here as well. So in fact,
I clean that in the long run.
And it's amazing people who,
those Republicans haven't noticed this
in the long run you over 30 or 40 years,
it's obvious that the stock market and
wages are pretty close, are correlated.
I mean, you know, if the stock
market collapses, you know,
that's disaster for
America and sh you know,
you can be sure the wages are going to
go down to if our stock market's booming
in America's incredibly successful,
it's a sure thing that in 40 years,
if the stock market is just booming along,
wages are going to be higher as well.
So if you get the wages of the
generation 30 years from now, you know,
in the, in the democratic plan you are
actually getting equity like returns,
but you're getting an advantage,
which is that the wages move slowly so
of all the stocks are bouncing up and
down.
So somebody who retired in the year 2007,
if he held stock and sold
that when he retired,
he could get a huge pension where
someone who retired in 2008, uh,
and sold the stock just when he retired,
he would be crushed because
the stock market lost 50% okay.
So that will never happen if you just
pay according to wages because they're
much stable.
All right?
But wages in the long run are
correlated with stocks in the long run,
in the short run, they just
don't fluctuate as much.
So, so what it was my plan.
Okay. So those are just some preliminary
observations and I'll give you the plan.
Okay. And then as I said, this
is obviously controversial.
I think I've identified the problem in
a scientific way that is everyone who,
you know, would agree with me if
they, if they knew enough economics.
But now my plan, even people who do know
as much as me might disagree with me,
but I, I, okay, but so this is what I
would, uh, okay. So here's the plan.
Okay. As I said, other plans
just say, well, things are bad.
Let's just keep the same system.
And so there are two basic ideas.
The democratic ideas,
let's just keep adjusting at the margin
will make up for it by giving people
money later. We'll do all kinds of things
like that. Maybe we'll raise some taxes,
reduced some benefits,
balanced the system,
the Republicans want to junk the whole
thing and privatized and let people,
you know, force them to save. But put it
in the stock market, in their own account.
Okay, now here's my plan. Um,
I don't have time to talk
about bushes plan. Um,
okay.
So here's my plan.
Number one,
the fact that we gave all this money
away to people in the forties and 50s and
60s and 70s, why should that
be the responsibility of the,
um, the workers today? I mean, our
government decided it was a good idea.
Roosevelt and Frances Perkins decided
we had to rescue the old of the forties
and our congresses kept that
up for the next 20, 30 years.
Even though the old Warrington's
such dire shape, but they kept up,
maybe it was not a good idea.
It's probably a very good idea.
But because we have that huge debt,
why should workers be the only people
responsible for paying back that debt?
I would start by imposing a legacy
tax on everybody. You know, um,
not for social security,
just for the debt we accumulated by
giving it to those old generations.
So I believe that would be something
like 1%. Uh, I wrote two to 3%,
but I think it's closer to 1% actually on
all income. If I did it on all Lincoln,
we'd be like 1% and that fun would pay
off for the social security legacy.
So then if we were starting the system
of fresh, how should we do it? Okay.
So,
um,
and that's some countries like Chile
decided they're going to start a fresh.
So how should we start a fresh,
having gotten rid of this old debt
that was hanging over our heads? Well,
um, uh, where does, what would I do?
I would have what I call
progressive personal accounts.
So I like all the Republican
ideas of knowing what you've got,
making it yours and making it transparent.
I think that's all an extremely good idea.
But why should it be that that comes from
putting your money into stocks? I mean,
stocks,
this is an old fashioned security and
it's incredibly risky from one year to the
next. That totally, I like the
idea of Shit, you know, of a,
of indexing something to wages.
So I want to create a new security that
I call personal annuitized average wage
security.
So what this does,
this is the security that just pays
proportional to the wage in the whole
country at the year you
retire. So whenever you, uh,
earn money on social security, so I'm
running out of time, so I don't want to,
I'm going to skip over this
pretty quickly. So if you
earn a dollar and you pay,
let's say 12% and social security's taxes,
that income,
now I'm going to, um, that income,
I'm going to say that's your
income. Okay? It's your 12%,
you're going to be forced to save it.
And what you're forced to do
is to buy these securities.
So it's a new kind of security
that pays proportional to the wage.
So it might pay 10, you know, 1% of the
average way. So We'd pay 12 cents here,
30 cents here,
and three quarters of a scent there.
That's the wage and the economy and
would pay, you know, 1% of that.
And how much of it when you get to buy
as much as you could afford to buy with
your security,
with your tax contribution.
Now that almost replicates
the current system.
The only difference is that, um, it
doesn't replicate the current system.
There's nothing progressive about it yet.
So what I would do is I would make
it a progressive tax. You know,
if you're making a hugely high income,
I wouldn't give you the whole
12% I would take part of it.
And if you're making a really low income,
I would have the government
subsidize it a little bit.
So instead of getting 12% of your low
income, you'd get a little more than 12%.
If you had a high income,
you're 12% tax, you know,
some of the government would take one
of those 12 away from you and you'd only
have 11% that you got to put in your
personal account. Okay. And then, um, now,
but it has a tremendous
advantage the system,
which is that if you can price the pause,
if you know what the market price of
pauses, then you're balancing the system.
Okay. Because every time
you hand somebody money,
you don't make some crazy promise
that when you get to be old,
I'm going to pay you
such and such dollars.
Like the current system is you're
letting the guy or the woman,
let's say who's working, she's buying
her own social security benefits.
So the, the, the, the benefits have an
equal value to what she's paying for.
So you've balanced the system,
you know from the, the,
the legacy tax you got rid of by having
the tax on everybody have one or 2% and
the uh,
balancing system going
forward is occurring because
you're forcing people to buy
their social security benefits. So anyway,
that's my, in a nutshell, my system.
And the last thing is how are you going
to get pause priced by the market? Well,
I'm going to get the market to trade them
and I think that would be a tremendous
boon to the economy if we had
these securities paid. Why is that?
Because they're tremendous.
Okay. So how would I do that?
I'd force everybody to
invest only in pause,
which I claim her likes stocks in
the long run, but in the short run,
they're risky.
So it's a better investment vehicle,
but they have to sell exactly 10%
of their paws into the market.
And with that 10% of money they could
hold stocks or whatever else they wanted
to and those 10% would all be pooled
together and the traded in the market and
the market then would have
an idea of, you know, a,
a new instrument to price what they
think future wages are going to be.
So anybody giving a pension plan that's
indexed a future wages would know what
the market price of those things are.
So it would dramatically help
pension plans as well. Anyway,
that's my idea of the,
uh, for social security.
So I have four minutes left and I
want to end with one last thought.
Okay. One last idea,
which is black shoals.
Now we've already done black
Sholes and a few problem sets.
So what is the idea of black shoals?
It's just like the idea of the
example we gave. By the way, you know,
if you do come next week and you want
to question me about my social security
plan and criticize it, I'd be
thrilled to be criticized because, um,
you know, you can't learn anything
unless you're criticized. And I, I,
I think I can defend it
too. But, uh, anyhow,
this is an idea which obviously hasn't
caught on yet because social security
reforms stopped.
We've got worst problems to worry about,
but if we get through this crisis,
the very next thing on Obama's agenda is
going to be reforming social security.
So I'm ready anyway. So
let me just end with, uh,
with the black shoals. So
in 1972, black and shoals,
uh, wrote a famous paper.
And what did they do?
They started off by saying,
this model we had you
see of the stock market,
which follows a geometric random walk
and can go up by a certain percentage or
down by a certain percentage. We've
used that with interest rates to, okay,
they can go up or down
by a certain percentage.
Here are the stocks can go up
or down by a certain percentage.
We saw that you could solve models like
that very easily. So black and shoals,
Fisher black, who was a great economist
and Myron shoals who won the Nobel prize,
but it was not as mathematical
as Fischer black. Anyway,
he started the hedge fund,
long capital fish of Myron shoals was
one of the people they looked in 1972 at
the returns each day on the s and p
500 and they bend them up like this.
So here are the number of times
the return was between, you know,
0.47% and some other number.
Okay.
And then they compared that to a normally
distributed random variable and look
how close to normally distributed
as it's practically like that.
So this thing over here
is the normally exactly,
normally distributed and this
is the frequency, you know,
graph of what actually happened that year.
Incredibly close to normally distributed.
And if you take the cumulative occurrence
of each thing and compare it to the
normal, it's incredibly close to
the normal. So they said, Gosh,
isn't it great this model of things
going up or down by a certain percentage
every year?
Maybe with a drift.
That's exactly the model of the
stock market seems to follow.
And maybe interest rates fall
that thing sort of model too.
And that's why we've worked
with all those models.
Well it turns out if you make those
assumptions and then you try to solve for
uh, option prices, you can do it
very quickly through some formula,
which I'm not going to have time to
present, but so when we take one minute,
but I'm going to skip that. So
what happened then? So this,
so this, uh, so this, um,
this was the second high point of,
you know,
there's the cap m model and
then the black Sholes model.
You've done problems with black Sholes
now and the problem set to figure out the
value of a call option.
So I'm just pointing out that you could
put it in a spreadsheet like I've done,
which will be on the, on the web and
you can do, you know, for 10, you know,
daily returns and fix the
standard deviation and stuff
and do backward induction
incredibly quickly and figure
out the value of the call option.
Even get a closed forum formula for it.
So that was,
and then explain why call option
prices have the form that they do.
So it was a great triumph and it
relied on their things being normally
distributed down to 30 seconds.
So what happened if you do the same
thing recently so you do exactly the same
thing and been everything up
like Fischer black did. Okay.
Not 1972 shit,
sorry.
Not In 1972 but you know the last five
years, say they only did one year,
but you do the last fight.
Actually I did this a couple of years ago.
So from seven years ago to two years ago,
if the pink thing is normally distributed
and we do the same binning that
blackened shoals did look everyday at
what the return is and sticking in a Ben
and just do the frequency thing.
What do you see?
You see that there are a lot more times
where in reality the move was very
small, but there are a lot more times
in reality where the move was very big.
So this is precisely what you call
a fat tail, that you get mold,
you know, smaller moves than
the normally distributed ones,
but also bigger moves the normally
distributed one so you can have some big
negative moves. And so we know, we've said
I had some huge negative shocks. Okay.
So I'm ending now with this thought that
finance produced remarkable theories,
remarkably precise predictions.
And for decades at a time it seemed
those were born out in practice.
But then looking back 50 years later
or 30 years later on these discoveries,
we see that they don't do quite as well
as they seem to be doing at first glance.
So some things missing in the theory.
And I think the subject is so exciting
because it's so connected to the world.
You know, everybody talks about
finance nowadays, you can't,
I mean any dinner part,
anyone in the world is spending half
their time thinking about finance.
And the theory is still up in the
air because the old, you know,
classics of the theory no longer hold.
And so it's an exciting time
to be developing a new theory,
and maybe you'll think
about it in the future.
So I'll see you some of you next week.